mislabeled products sold to mislead
customers not synthetic but rabbits
raccoon dog Fox mink and even cats for
the past 15 months Sky News has
documented how faux fur isn't always
fake our findings took center stage in a
parliamentary inquiry
a stood the boxes if the major high
street stores we featured contamination
of the supply chain is happening in
certain brands this could happen in any
brand and today the Environment Food and
Rural Affairs Committee have published
their report their verdict is damning
complacent retailers and poor labeling
legislation are failing
consumers the inquiry chair is now
calling on the government to change the
law Sky News you brought it very much to
our attention that there was real fur
being sold as fake fur we found the
retailers were not finding the real fur
trading standards were not fit for
purpose and we want to see a public
consultation done by the government as
the weather in future we should actually
ban fur labor say they back a ban and
animal rights campaigners are confident
they have consumer support
branch you are still pedaling firm there
consumers are becoming increasingly
isolated when brands like be achieved my
proposed and Musashi all banker from
their collection of the last twelve
months but do shoppers want to have the
choice there is such a big thinking
about here whereas I think to be honest
in Istanbul in Turkey it's seen as a
almost a status symbol about leather
shoes next nation and loved animals I
think it's just definitely the way to go
the spotlight of scrutiny has already
influenced British fashion a lot of
magazines in the UK won't shoot fair at
all and haven't shot fur for some years
and even the stores are kind of taking
note of this and Selfridges stopped
selling fair in 2004 and a support a
stopped last year was when they made
their announcement but four years before
that you wouldn't have been able to find
any on the side and matches are working
with Livia fair at the moment on a code
of conduct to govern all of their brands
that they buy so even if designers make
fur they'll find they can't sell it in
the UK trends come and go but this one
is gaining traction it's up to
politicians and the public to decide if
they want to follow in this fashion so
our hash McGary Sky News